à travers
seules les séries time en direct ce soir
le prime de la vérité je vous le dis ça
va être fou c'est fou ce qui va se
passer ce soir matthieu delormeau dans
un instant vous verrez ce qui va vous
arriver
jean luc lemoine il y aura quarante
minutes de 4/3 ça va arriver là dans
quelques instants
isabelle morini bosc elle sera dans la
voiture il y aura chico et les gypsies à
l'arrière ils vont jouer des titres vous
allez voir ce qui se passe là ils sont
en train de s'échauffer
ça va être énorme mais pour l'instant
c'est notre camille combal ring la
vérité sur les chroniqueurs et oui les
amis la vérité surtout ronny coeur parce
que la petite julie qu'on a vu il ya un
instant un 10 ans qui imite cyril je
veux la rassurer cyril c'est pas devenu
le trublion tout le monde adore du jour
au lendemain il s'est cherché longtemps
cyril humoristiquement fait un peu tout
le monde
frilosité rement à ce qu'à une époque
l'an de grâce 2008 cyril animer les
bêtisiers de france 3 a rasé comme
jamais un gars comme jamais le lancement
avec une petite voix aiguë pour finir
chaque lancement magnifique élégant de
son père aussi à liège pas pourquoi il a
abattu le soleil vient de se coucher
encore une belle soirée dans notre grand
bêtisier quand on a des invités
ingérable comme omar et fred sur le jt
de france 2 on est sûr que ça va partir
en live
allez on va s'intéresser aux blondes et
elles sont vraiment très blonde qu'on ne
pouvait pas s'en priver
ce sont les inoubliables du site et il
n'y a pas à dire ce sont vraiment de
bons clients
fait pas fini voici le lancement je suis
seul sur un bateau j'ai trouvé deux
accessoires qui traînait je me suis ça
pourrait même sortir de la galère mais
en fait ça me précipite direct dans le
vide ici bravo humain voilà donc comme
ceci quand on voit quelqu'un on aime
encore plus utile jean-pierre on rajoute
ceci voilà c'est sympa c'est bien c'est
ça
mais on a pire le plateau en direct en
cours de tango noter le look de cyril à
côté mais graisser miley cyrus
[Musique]
20 de ce paquebot et là nous sommes dans
la salle du tango l'attention à ce sont
des maestros 3 vous pas réveiller les
gens vad
mais le look il est incroyable mais la
rose en hercule poirot la rose mais les
gangs à tous c'est dégueulasse oui c'est
dégueulasse mais la nouvelle star ne
touche pas à mon poste est allé c'est
bien sûr matthieu delormeau à laver nrj
12 pour nous rejoindre alors que c'était
quand même le leader du mac d'nrj12
meneur d'hommes respecté par ses équipes
ouais enfin quasiment sauf derrière lui
en discret pendant que mathieu dit au
revoir aux gens fassent qu'à mais qui ne
les voit pas et d enlever c'est pour ça
qu'il a redressé pour se référer de
doute
[Musique]
c'est souvent
c'était sympa sympa mais moins qu'ici
bas sur nrj12 mathieu aussi animer une
émission qu'on a oublié trop vite un
immense événement qu'il est même stressé
de présenter le soir venu là les
pétoches regard des allumettes que ça va
bien pas trop stressé tout quoi mais
c'est l'événement ce soir sur nrj 12
l'événement sur nrj 12 mais de quoi on
parle les nma the voice mais non c'est
la grande première de bouffe culture à
la hauteur
mais non c'est ouf à la recherche du
meilleur chien l'émission n'a pas
cartonné pourtant mathieu énergie vous
avez tout donné sur le jury a parterre
de stars pour un jury quel jury on
ad'abord eve angeli bonsoir ève sophie
thalmann patrick pita vino et enfin
sébastien khoury que vous pouvez
applaudi connaissez le bien forcé ben
l'émission était aussi père a menti avec
des épreuves pareil je me demande encore
pourquoi l'émission n'est pas devenue
culte
tout est vraiment c'est la demi finale
en jeu une place pour la demi finale
maintenant vos deux héros vont
s'affronter sur une épreuve
véritablement spectaculaire regarder
quoi cette voie si la deuxième épreuve
un magicien va faire léviter une
saucisse devant le chien qui ne pourra
en aucun cas la crau qui est l'événement
ce soir sur nrj 12
[Applaudissements]
ah oui là là on est dans l'événement
raoui de la vérité c'est pas ma vérité
c'était raté les extraits vidéo ou en
fait cette émission c'est quand c'est
fini tu t'es où ça aurait plus que les
plus spéciales vérité il est temps de
vous apprendre une chose que peu de gens
le savent
sur isabelle morini-bosc sécurisé à pour
un porte un lourd secret pardon depuis
des années mais en réalité il a et
esteban des mystérieuses cités d'or sont
la même et unique personne bijoux à sec
tout lié à l'époque a été déjà passionné
de télévisa elle faisait des interviews
on a une image regarder on le fait tout
ce qu'il y avait de l'est dans cette
profession et c'est ça qu'il faut bien
vous mettre dans la tête
l'expression prendre levis joli conte à
l'udps en valeur
c'est bonne foi de martine lamoril est
alors toujours on dirait josiane balasko
jeunes très belle aussi
est ce que vous l'avez nouvelle
d'ailleurs d abel morini-bosc isabelle
morini-bosc s'il vous plaît à voilà elle
va arriver
[Musique]
ce soc ça ça va être fou ça va être fou
dans un instant elle va me maudire la
maison où le 10 mai mais grâce à
isabelle morini bosc
je vous le dis peut-être que deux
personnes dans le public partiront au
parc astérix et deux personnes sur
twitter
les gars
j'ai déconné on est en prime
si isabelle morini-bosc gagne c'est tout
le public qui en
[Applaudissements]
et c'est m
[Musique]
vous croyez quoi bah oui alors ça va
être la belle mais je vous jure que
c'est pas sûr qu'elles gagnent parce
qu'elle va on va me défoncer la caf à me
défoncer la gueule
allez d'autres vocables oui je suis
tombé sur une pépite des images d'un
chroniqueur qui nous avait caché un
projet en cours
mais comme c'est le problème de la
vérité soir on se dit tout faux tout se
dire est ce que l'un d'entre eux vont
autour de la table va jouer dans un film
prochainement à moi oui peut-être joué
dans un procès pour vous avez déjà
tourné j'ai tourné c'est exactement la
durée du séjour il ya trois semaines
c'est quoi votre rôle
un coach en séduction
avant les premières images on a les
premières images du film à l'autre
rappelle quand même
rappelez-vous jean-mi nous avait alors
tout n'est pas mixer et tout un concert
de volant mais c'est vraiment les images
volées tour d'être libre ce gens me nous
avait déjà montré une vraie fille
théâtrale dans une pub pour les
cigarettes électroniques
ah oui avec toute la finesse qu'on
connaît agents mis ce je ne sais quoi
rappeler aux cartes il est énorme
j'ai toujours un ego sur moi comment
dire démesuré tu préfères pas une petite
pipe
après l'interview promis et bien après
un tel succès tous les producteurs de
paris on tape les gens me et bien voici
les premières images de son long métrage
à venir en jean gabin à regarder arrêt
de voiliers le temps pour ça qu'on joue
un tout petit peu j'ai 80 non plus dire
on allait parler parce qu'il ya pas mal
de taf
je plains complètement sous vaudrey
nature de son voeu moi je crois tu crois
mais l'écriture c'est bon non
la médaille d'or
[Musique]
on s'est permis de vous faire une petite
bande annonce avec un peu plus de scènes
sans dévoiler trop l'intriguent c'est
des vrais scène tuera dans l'oeuf il m'a
juste fait gaffe omar sy le record
d'intouchable tient plus qu'à ça ça
regarde pour la première fois sur vos
écrans
jean michel maire dans un film avec de
l'action
des dialogues maîtrisé
victoire de viol jeu le pack monde en ce
sens dans la deûle aventure
[Applaudissements]
alors n'attendez pas
foncez très bientôt cris de chez vous
pour voir fast and zombies cdrs elle
[Applaudissements]
veut dire quand même pas le seul de
l'équipe à s'être essayé à la commedia
dell'arte cyrille adoula non entre deux
bêtisier sur france 3 a joué dans un
court métrage
ça s'appelait un autre monde quoi ça et
c'est vrai que si tu viens de voir
scarface tu tombes sur cyril et tu dis
que c'est un autre nom de zhu lors de
gens battent jeunesse au port à l'image
voyez gens battent là il avec son mec
qu'a déjà mais c'est énorme ça vous
écoutez bien il ya tous les potes de
celle de l'époque sa vraie cour et raja
ya jonathan lambert ya arrêt habitants
je crois que - venu pour moi de me
retirer
rideau les trois coups à sa place aux
talents encore place au patron vous
connaissez la dernière blague sur les
hétéros arrête gens battent pas cette
histoire allait vraiment dégueu bah ça
va kadja l'adorent en tout cas moi ça
fait trois ans que je bosse avec gabriel
je n'ai encore jamais vu avec un garçon
tu serais pas un petit peu et héron
refoulés sur les bords on arrête gens
battent presse appelant petit ami
frédéric ou frédérique avec 1 c à la fin
j'espère vous n'allez quand même pas le
virer et puis quoi encore
on va pas garder un hétéro dans la boîte
du petit poisson faut de la réserve
pourquoi tu les connais pas ces jours là
c'est des gros vicieux il a raison et 4
j'en ai fait les frais est il vraiment
une interface voir
mais a suivi l'animal et 4 et 4
jalonnent ce bond réalisé par david
haddad qu'excellents lui voilà ouais les
gars en coup droit jalsa un peu avec 4
j'aille très beau catch attack bon
renard oui tu vois alors j'ai revu mes
prétentions à la baisse
je rêvais la peau d'ébène pouvez pas
vous laisser aller pour finir sans un
dernier best of des costumes de cyril la
dernière fois j'ai pris un fou rire en
ressortant les lancements d'une vieille
émission
obama avait décidé de se déguiser au
temple à toi tu ne sais pas pourquoi il
est tout seul sur un fond vert
je pensais que c'était pas possible mais
j'en ai trouvé encore des meilleurs
j'aime bien aussi la petite entrée
malicieuse au début à la matmut comme ça
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau et n'oubliez
pas comme le disait si bien georges des
tarifs plus on est de fous plus on rit à
la télé le péril jeune s'est abattue sur
le divertissement dans cette catégorie
voici justement un des meilleurs duos
antoine de caunes et josé garcia ont
donc compter parmi les meilleures du
modélisme 17 fois le journaliste a été
écarté de la télé pour insolence on
reprend donc les grands classiques on
détourne les tubes c'est la grande
riscle et c'est un brocoli qui vous le
dit insolence rime avec excellence
regardez
[Applaudissements]
très vite les séries et nohra
enora j'ai une vérité sur vous et nord
et nohra vous êtes une très grande
chanteuse d'opéra vous avez fait de
l'opérette
non mais c'est vrai vous avez pris des
très grandes j'ai quand j'étais plus
jeune j'ai fait un peu de corps à louey
j'adorais le chant lyrique et bien et
nora vous allez partir parce que
regarder vite on vous attend regardez où
regarder
bon alors mais c'est quoi ça mathieu non
non non non non
non seriez vous attend à l'opéra y aura
des gens dans l'esprit avec des gens
dans la salle
je vous jure que c'est vrai
alors on va retrouver leur à l'instant
allez-y et on se braque de la vérité
avant avant d'avoir son luxueux mois des
soldes il aura une très très grosse
surprise pour quelqu'un ici autour de
cette table juge que c'est pourquoi elle
va à l'opéra moi j'étais chez michou ses
deux salles deux ambiances douces à deux
on ne vous inquiétez pas isabelle est ce
que vous entendez isabelle isabelle sa
valise à isa savant ma chérie isabelle
isabelle ça va il ya quand même un mec
au téléphone je dors à la [ __ ] à l'eau
isabelle ça va elle m'entend pas
isabelle saba isabelle massé sur
[Rires]
alors grave et ma chérie vous allez
jouer pour envoyer tout le public dans
un parc d'attraction avec un gars avec
une grosse moustache
d'accord ça vous fait plaisir ça vous
fait plaisir
oui je pense que je vais faire alors je
vais vous expliquer c'est très simple ce
soir on va vous offrir votre deuxième
cours de conduite d'accord m'entendais
très bien
yann chico et les gypsies qui font du
stop faut être préparé à cette
éventualité
ils vont chanter et isabelle comme vous
vous doucher tous les deux jours vous
allez passer au rouleau d'accord essayer
de remonter
vous allez devoir reconnaître ce un tube
des années 80 interprété par chico et
les gypsies avant que le lavage ne se
termine d'accord c'est bon alors si j'y
arrive pas ça va quoi et bat tout le
monde perd au shérif de chaque fois que
quelqu'un qui pâtit
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet automne vous inquiétez pas c'est
sofiane il est très sympa il y aura
trois plutôt ceux ci tiré au sort vous
pouvez jouer http vérité qu'ils vont
gagner un séjour 4 4 entre les puces une
nuit à l'hôtel
offerte d'accord isabelle souilah prête
vous êtes prête
bon bah vous êtes prêtre fait rien alors
juste j'ai oublié un truc alors elle va
démarrer vous inquiétez pas juste vous
je vous les voyez un truc vous avez
remonter la vitre si c'est ça vous avez
inventé la vitre ou pas d'accord c'est
bloqué
[Applaudissements]
allez isabelle est ce que vous êtes
prête
isabelle que messier six mois oui mais
bon je vais m'en c'est monsieur côté
cdti des années 90 allez c'est parti au
débat c'est parti c'est parti allez-y
c'est parti on les bat vie
tous les compteurs durée
[Musique]
c'est pas
masai et farid ont même dansé
allez allez allez allez attendez
attendez les gypsies c'est bon vous avez
un tic soient trouvées sac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit de rue une cache pas pour tous
c'est donc un super bon alors c'est quoi
sa poule vérité si ces bons avec moi
je crois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
3 à côté de sa mère et l enfant je redis
c'est tout son être de la sphère du jour
la fonte on n'est pas au personnel
[Musique]
wes avant et ce moratoire
on est à des années à les entendre
encore 2
[Musique]
doodle débat
c'est quoi
[Musique]
j'suis leur dégaine enfants pauvres on
dit allez y ça se joue sur celle là
le mât s'est passé entre le conte des
histoires une autre de 10
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à lausanne
le but
[Applaudissements]
je te remets doucement
un drôle de voir tout à l'heure le but
sera surtout elle est ici c'est là et
merci merci à sofiane de permis malin du
mont valérien voilà qui est formidable
merci à isabelle bras dont isabelle
bravo
bravo si toi et les gypsies exceptionnel
exceptionnellement jean-luc avant de
rejoindre et nora qui va être à l'opéra
de paris
je propose que vous venez me rejoindre
est-ce que isabelle va venir nous
rejoindre également enora aussi mais
venez à côté de moi j'en avais besoin
d'elle même et vous inquiétez pas à la
haye
jean luc lemoine vient à côté de moi mon
jean luc jean luc lemoine est là parce
que jean luc je vais avoir besoin de
vous parce que je vais appeler mokhtar
j'aurais que mokhtar vienne me rejoindre
mokhtar soit qu'ils étaient là se
recoiffe mokhtar va venir parce que je
vous le dis on a un truc énorme pour
mokhtar dans un instant on a une vérité
sur mokhtar vous allez voir vos car il
fait le boulot car il fait le costaud et
mes mots car va bien fermer sa gueule
bah ouais et ben je le dis à tout de
suite spéciale vérité continuer à réagir
sur twitter vers sur http et des to qui
vous voulez voir sur le fauteuil du
détecteur de mensonges pour l'instant
c'est moi qui m'y colle voilà bien
m'avait choisie pour l'instant on va
voir si ça restera comme ça jusqu'au
bout de la soirée juste si vous nous
rejoignez seulement maintenant sachez
qu'il ya une personne autour de la table
qui pue de la gueule à votre avis de qui
il s'agit voilà merci d'angil ou encore
ti pour des bottes témoins des partis
pour les bonnes raisons
isabelle morini bosc à parvenir dans un
instant isabelle morini-bosc j'aimerais
qu'il revienne très vite isabelle morini
bosc et et je vous le dis il y a il ya
une séquence émotion qui va arriver dans
un instant regardez le regarder l'eau il
a des yeux bandés non mais on va on va
le faire rentrer dans un instant qu'un
délai les yeux bandés et vous allez voir
ce soir vous ne verrez plus jamais
mokhtar comme avant mais bon jean luc
avant avant que vous fassiez les
cafetières parce que les quatre tirs
arrivent ils à 20 minutes de quatre tirs
il en fera vingt minutes après en fin
d'émission ça veut dire qu'ils autant
vous dire qu'il a beaucoup beaucoup de
dossiers aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous
dévoiler une vérité savait que je suis
votre plus grand fan depuis très
longtemps j'ai peut-être mis du temps à
les voir votre dernier spectacle
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai mais sa cheikh depuis depuis
le début je n'ai vraiment rien louper je
me souviens encore de cette soirée
incroyable à la fête du lycée jacques
prévert à longjumeau
j'ai même tout filmé non regardez jean
luc lemoine frappe et ça bah oui j'ai
commencé à 28 ans j'ai joué vendredi
donc elle pas les images pas cette
personne les a salué un petit billet ils
ont tout donné à nos jours
c'était la fête du lycée de jean luc
lemoine taux trop mignon regardez le
[Applaudissements]
les ciseaux
il avait déjà perdu si j'ai ma poste
avait été filmé ça et la fête du poisson
vous en rappelez la fête du poisson et
des moments il faut passer à autre chose
parce que je vous rappelle que moi aussi
j'ai des dossiers sur vous même et la
fête du poisson c'était sa part gardé a
fait du poids sans regarder
[Applaudissements]
à tort
en fait chaud
allez
et là je savais même pas que c'était
filmé et c'était la nuit du poisson le
spectacle qui sent bon bah ouais c'est
un spectacle payant 1
c'est un spectacle payant je t'aurais
invité mon chéri vous fait le malin jean
michel maire parce que j'ai des petites
chaussures vous jean michel maire aussi
mais pas faire le malin voulait faire un
petit peu le malin mais juste avant on
va faire entrer mokhtar kate avec
monsieur rocard va s'installer
merci mokhtar fait attention qu'ils ne
tombent pas un motard mokhtar ça va ça
va il allait enfin beau car ce soir une
personne très spéciale est venu sur ce
plateau pour vous annoncer quelque chose
d'important
cette personne a n'ai jamais encore venu
dans notre émission c'est un peu une
séquence n'est que la vérité qui compte
vous rappeler de cette émission de tf1
présenté par pascal bataille et laurent
fontaine et bien je vous le dis il ya
des torrents d'émotion qui ont été
déversées dans cette émission sur tf1
et bien je peux vous dire que ce soir on
va tous être trempé comme isabelle vous
parlez de du happening et bien sûr parce
que la personne qui est derrière le
rideau est ici pour parler à beaucoup
d'armes au quartier là qui est installé
voltage que vous avez une idée de qui se
cache derrière le rideau
non vraiment pas ce que vous pouvez
parler plus fort parce que je ne vous
entends pas non vraiment pas pas ce
petit tour l'avocat
pensez vous à une personne que vous avez
totalement perdus de vue
perdu oui c'est à dire pas vu depuis
longtemps
je peux vous poser une question
maintenant qu'elle rideau pourquoi y'a
toujours un casque enfin quand je suis
devant les yeux c'est toujours mieux
balkans au cas où il prend l'avion a
gardé les cages est ce que il ya
quelqu'un qui a quelque chose à vous
reprocher mokhtar non non quoi ma femme
[Applaudissements]
alors motards il ya un premier indice
écoutez et regardez chez vous qui va
peut-être vous mettre sur la voie de qui
est cette personne regarde mokhtar que
penses tu du dicton tunisien une seule
babouche vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé commence à avoir une idée
mokhtar ou pas non aux perdreaux faisans
non non pas pour l'instant non occultée
n'en voyez de qui je veux parler ou pas
du tout n'entend pas notre indice il ya
un deuxième indice écouter bonjour me
tard tu as dit que le rugby était à
deuxième famille mais pourrais-tu tout
plaquer pour la première en corse pour
commencer à y voir plus clair
un petit peu re pense à qui ma mère
octave que vous lui enlevez le le cash
avions
bogota ce que vous voulez voir qui se
cache derrière le rythme moi oui
là je peux vous dire je m'attaque côté
de moctar ben moctar on va vous montrer
tout de suite qui est derrière le rideau
regardez qui veut vous parler ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là
ces mecs-là aux motards bons mots car
dans nos quartiers athénée merci d'être
là on a on à tenir mais la maman de deux
motards de tunisie et à la quelque chose
à dire à abu car oui mokhtar je veux ni
aujourd'hui esprits et pauvres parce que
je t'aime beaucoup et je ma part mon
petit fils aussi et je voyais n'est pas
venu seul ce soir à maman dota oui elle
a une surprise pour pour mokhtar ce soir
et je pense que ça va lui faire très
très plaisir on voulait le faire une
surprise déjà qu'il appartient à las
vegas déjà il va être comme un fou je
vous dis vous pouvez venir avec nous à
la moc ta à la bourse a souligné en écho
à las vegas
bocar manta et ya une surprise que tu as
fait ça ta maman ce soir est-ce que tu
étais content d'avoir parce qu'elle est
en tunisie et qu'il est comment vous pas
vu pour y dormir à la maison soit
mokhtar vous êtes venu avec qui je
venais avec 921 fatiha elle est venue
avec mes soeurs jumelles mais de gros
soeur jumelle j'ai pas vu depuis deux
trois ans avec les soeurs jumelles de
mokhtar qui l'a pas vu depuis trois ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notamment ce soir est et ça fait trois
ans que tu les as pas vu tes soeurs et
quoi et tu te dis va te des soeurs
jumelles comme ça ça fait que moi ton
but et a vu trois ans pour vous le
regardez un peu la télé ou par goût du
jour tous les jours il est formidable
oui est ce que cette réforme c'est un
cadeau que je voulais te faire présenter
ce soir elles sont venues voilà devoir
de tunisie elles vont rester avec toi
elles vont te bichonner maman va rester
là mam après nous on s'en occupera alors
mais mokhtar du très heureux pour toi et
tu crois qu'à maman merci la matière
fatiha et mocquard est vraiment je suis
très heureux que sur l'évier merci je
crois que c'est une magnifique surprise
provoque tard voilà mon chéri et ben on
voulait faire la surprise en tunisie
c'est elle qui reste
mais si tu veux vous allez tous c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau je vous ai réservé
l'hippopotamus juste et reste avec t'as
pas lu mon mothma on voulait tu sois
l'écho ce soir est vraiment passé un bon
moment quand elle sort merci
on confronte à remercie la jolie blonde
est magnifique alors merci beaucoup
monsieur mercier
les deux soeurs le mokhtar magnifiques
arbres et merci mokhtar merci pâtir à
bercy mais j'ai les bras bourré
il a failli me faire chialer ce qu'on
l'a non mais franchement c'est émouvant
sur l'udc s'était pas fou sans déconner
aussi j'aime pas plus real antennes je
suis sensible jaunards mais mais mais
mais mais mokhtar là je peux vous dire
la salle ça lui a fait quelque chose au
delà des nouvelles d'enora enora et nora
je crois qu'elle est dans la limousine
savary bras vous n'êtes pas tannés shota
l'opéra mais pas du tout mais vraiment
je reviens au cul là où est-ce qu'on a
si j'ai de la chance et merci beaucoup
mais en même temps cette limousine on
dirait un truc de prostituées donc je
sais pas trop alors ça l'est on m'a dit
que vous êtes à quelques pas de l'opéra
et doha vous allez arriver à l'opéra
donc vous vous y est je crois dans donc
dans quelques minutes un c'est ça
quelques secondes là vous êtes arrivées
le coeur vous êtes fou mais je vais vous
êtes arrivé à l'opéra ou pas mais on va
vraiment à l'opéra en plus
oui hélas japon n'est effectivement pas
loin on n'est pas loin le imputant à
long et à l'opéra à montier allez sortez
de la limousine à l'opéra est alors allé
souper à déposer n'aura à l'opéra elle
va y aller et elle va chanter vous
arrive vous avez préparé d'elle toute
chose et nora et n'aura non mais enfin
j'ai préparé en détente pape a enfin je
veux dire fin en colonie de vacances
quoi ans sous le feu quoi sympa j'avais
préparé quoi vous avez préparé quoi
carmen carmen carmen la mère de bella
email
alors allez-y aller à l'opéra et non la
maman de by naim mais allez-y et le
public vous attend à l'opéra et doha
regardez il ya mille personnes à
l'intérieur du 10 attendent
allez-y vous êtes attendus à les aidera
non non mais c'est pas pousser suis allé
à les 11 et 20 cibles allez c'est un peu
je n'arrive pas y croire je n'y crois
pas c'est passé un peu ça va être
l'enfer j'ai même tapé la honte de ma
vie ça va être catastrophique
c'est mes adieux à la vie à la toule à
la cenal est génial et dépêchez vous
battez vous attend
en même temps c'est génial
lb l'entrée n'est ce pas quel très belle
entrée à la lie à personne je vais pas
chanter dehors quand même
enora à les ai demandé au jour là il
sait fermer quoi c'est fermé mais vous
faites une vieille vannes et doha
reprenez la voiture bonjour mais non
reprenez la voiture et n'aura en fait on
s'est trompé c'est dit m le loi c 10
mètres cloyes reprenez la voiture en
prenez la voiture
faites attention en descendant les
marches ah ouais d'accord j'aime
retrouver dans un vieux bouge mais leur
vélo alors elle retrait dans un bouge et
des cracheurs de feu et des chevaux pour
rien mais alors allez vite et bien ça
m'arrange
allez-y allégé allez-y allez-y vous
allez chanter à l'opéra on vous l'a
promis enora va chanter à l'opéra son
public l'a t'on elle a préparé qu'à lens
ça va être dans le métro l'opéra c'est
ça mais c'est comme ça allait vite à les
et à les regarder et laura saint gobain
qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est pas possible
avait fait ce qu'ils font c'est parti on
repart bon je préfère en même temps ce
qu'est l'opéra merci vous allez chanter
à l'opéra il devra regarder c'est parti
ça y est il est reparti le gala ben non
le gars prend goût prend du temps allez
y en a on apprit nouvelles personnes en
plus un bon joueur réputé de le cul
nature chico quelques kits vous ils ont
pris un enfant le gars a pris un enfant
allez j'allais voir des enfants aller
dans la lah serait génial vous allez
voir on va vous amener vous allez à là
l'opération monsieur la smart
non mais vous occupez pas de chat il a
l'habitude d'aller regarder n'aura vous
allez kiffer et l'aura conduit un peu
chelou un gt je vous connais je vous
connais ça va tu vieille vanasse a pas
bientôt je vais tôt là là je sens que ça
où est ce qu'on veut c'est ça quelque
part
voilà regarder ça alors là on se dirige
vers la place vendôme un qualcomm alors
enora il est il très belle vie vous
savez la nuit vous at il à répéter ou
pas oui parce que vraiment votre public
vous attend à l'opéra regarde un peu
papa feulement mais un petit peu mais
pas non plus est ce que vous êtes arrivé
là qu est-ce qu ici voila voila regardez
vous allez arriver encore vous allez
voir j'arrive dans une rue très louche
non car elle ou chien sait rien un petit
quoi ce délire
j'ai quand même pas me retrouver dehors
à ses avants d'enfoirés est ce qu'on
peut voir jérôme revon à la région qui
bavent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez les bras on vous attend à
l'intérieur votre public vous attend à
l'extérieur ouest à l'extérieur mais
c'est super alors enora ya quand même un
gars très à l'aise qu'il a réécrit pas
tranquille le gars il est dans le trou
enora ce que vous allez bien répéter et
n'aura non mais j'ai chanté la wii vous
allez chanter là vous êtes prêté de rang
je sens bah oui vous avez raison qu'il
ya ait des freaks derrière oui vous avez
répété il avait répété
allez c'est parti mais si répéter mais
enfin là c'est vrai que c'est tout à
fait ça allait aller s'il vous plaît on
y va attention et laura est ce que vous
êtes prêts mais ce qu'on sait aller non
mais c'est mais c'est hyper bon je vais
faire aller ils vont vous accompagner
attention les gens chez lui mais alors
en baisse y fait attention
est-ce que vous est ce qu'on est prêt à
les enora ça va être avant mais j'ai
envoyé là bas
est ce qu'on peut avoir un plan
d'ensemble s'il vous plaît merci au
revoir de la rue pour moi un peu la rue
etc
merci attention
c'est parti
[Musique]
on peut voir on peut voir les personnes
qui prennent les photos tout ça merci
regardez c'est la tristesse infinie et
laura allez on vous écoute aller s'il
vous plaît si on pouvait mettre le micro
rapidement merci rien ne me parle pas
j'attends c'est robocop aller bercy ça
il a comme ça c'est bon je fais par
dessus d'accord attention mais laura ba
ba oui bonsoir non mais bon vous fait
faire un truc vraiment hardcore là comme
tout seul comme ça on y va enora ennuis
allez c'est ça vous aidera
c'est parti allez y allez musique
[Musique]
pour celui qu'on vient de refuser
mais c'est nous
si lui convient
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
fribourg à côté ce qui m'est arrivé
l'agent lui que moi le roman tu viens me
voir j'aurais moins bon c'est bon
souvenir sans nous merci il ya un moment
là jean luc lemoine qui bien sûr moi et
qui me dit excuse moi il ya un pige ou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la ménopause présentiez ciridd il ya un
pigeon à la fenêtre en temps normal moi
je lui dis juste inquiète cp doha bravo
une aura été formidable c'était fort ce
qu'elle a fait un merci jérôme gendreau
merci alors à vous avez et
exceptionnellement merci la franchement
espoir ou pas
il est encore elle passe une bonne
soirée et a passé une bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
j'avais des skis là bas qu'est ce qu'il
ya qu'est-ce qu'il ya un
qu'est ce qui a alourdi mais quand je
vois comme je vous disais mais je me
rends que ça serait mieux si vous nous
aimez pas non mais franchement mais quoi
de durand et c'est tout le père puis
j'ai loupé inquiète pas du tout cas elle
n'aura c'était génial
en même temps je suis contente pas
m'arrêter là seuls à en prendre
merci vous voulez faire des commentaires
sur les missions de l'école s'en est pas
remis à sa voix qui attendait pas du
tout il s'en est pas remis bah oui c'est
vrai merci que voulez vous les faire un
petit bilan des missions et vélizy
poursuivre et c'est à vous inquiétez pas
vous n'êtes pizza pour les questions aux
tirs mais juste avant les questions en
4/3 les shihri il y a notre matthieu
delormeau à les y installer la chaise
puisque ça va être la vérité de matthieu
delormeau et oui
matthieu delormeau s'il ya une vérité
que vous ne pouvez pas nier c'est que
vous dit toujours la vérité
c'est vrai ou pas ouais matthieu
delormeau on va vous demander de vous
installer sur ce siège
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mathieu mathieu on va les y les chéris
mathieu peut s'installer
matthieu delormeau pour la vérité on se
souvient de matthieu delormeau souvient
du témoignage édifiant de virginie efira
qui disait que vous avez toujours voulu
être célèbre
ah merde matthieu delormeau le 11
janvier dernier
matthieu delormeau avait été décoré du
melon d'or
regardez je veux vraiment un truc qui
m'est venue en tête quand j'ai vu
recevoir le melon d'or ouais bah voilà
donc je me souviens qu'il m'avait dit
qu'un jour tu serais connu tout aussi ah
oui et tu refusais le générique des
émissions de patrick sabatier
c'est vrai les avis de recherche ah oui
tu misère recherche matthieu delormeau
non
[Applaudissements]
alors là c'est vrai j'avais dit quand on
a 5 syllabes on a plus de chance je
pense de devenir un côté d'accor c'est
quoi ton des deux lacs de la connerie
aussi où là on l'a beaucoup de gens
désireux faites-nous avis de recherche
des sas et avis de recherche ça va
commencer
avis de recherche matthieu delormeau
taylor wood avec le soir matthieu
delormeau vous souvenez des missions le
packtec savatier avis de recherche je me
souvenais également du jeu de la vérité
absolument voilà on se rappelle les des
plus grandes stars un sas ayez main sur
ce siège et devait dire la vérité est
bien mathieu raynal qui ont laissé une
carrière merci il va avoir des bruits
clôture n'hésitez pas et bien vous allez
donc être sur ce siège et il ya beaucoup
de gens qui veulent vous posez des
questions mathieu vous allez avoir de
joker comme dans l'émission d'accord de
joker et par exemple vous rappelez de
coluche dans le jeu de la vérité
ouais la grille et d'eau des bus way
regardez alors allez-y l'attention aux
points svp je tiens tout de suite à
rassurer téléspectateurs il y en a pour
une heure et demie mais pour aller
pisser il ya des chanteurs
première question 787 22-22 bonsoir
madame c'est à vous oui bonsoir joker un
joker drôle de guerre
ah oui vous avez loin de joker je veux
pas cette question là ça me plaît pas
de toute façon posée vous pourrez
questions que vous voulez j'ai les
réponses un deuxième question 787 22 27
à vos bons soirs joker
voilà maintenant les pédales
mathieu il y aura des questions du
public il y aura des questions des
téléspectateurs sur twitter il y aura
des questions que des proches à vous ou
enregistrez je pense mathieu que vous
avez étonné par le nombre de gens qui
ont enregistré une question je pense que
ça va vous faire plaisir
bien sûr je suis pas sûre et m'a dit
mathieu déjà moi j'ai une question pour
vous parce qu'à une question des des
questions des chroniqueurs
déjà première question facile alors vous
avez d'autres jokers
ici vous appeler ici allez je rajoute un
joker 3 de joker ci voulait pas répondre
mais attention si vous répondez pas il
peut vous arriver quelque chose mais je
vous le dis ah bah c'est normal bah oui
où vous êtes toujours des nouilles
quelque part mathieu première question
pour moi est ce que tu peux nous
raconter la fois où tu as le plus
profité de la notoriété mathieu non mais
vous n'avez pas fini ça quand même
la fois où j'ai le plus profité de ma
notoriété
à en boîte de nuit
en soirée sous les effets eh ben je vais
passer tout le monde je suis rentré du
coup tranquillement et après moi j'ai
une table à l'oeil les boissons à l'oeil
j'ai rien payer voilà c'est cool c'est
ça c'est tout ouais c'était belle merde
miles kane question pour matthieu
delormeau ici dans l'équipe thierry
moreau allez-y si cyril te demandait de
faire tes pmt gratuitement tu le ferais
par amour pour lui honnêtement je mens
jamais vous c'est vrai ouais
honnêtement oui parce que honnêtement
oui parce que c'est pas la blague
cd oui c'est pas le fais pas mon
principal revenus d'accor a oui ou non
cette quoi vous faites des la confiserie
en a mais j'ai une boîte de production
je produis à côté et voilà d'accord
valérie venez vous avez une question oui
on sait que tu es déjà partis en
vacances avec enora mais à l inverse
avec lequel d'entre nous ne pourrait
jamais partir est pourquoi avec le cas
je pourrais jamais partir alors rien de
personnel mais je pense thierry parce
que je pense que je me ferais chier
merci c'est pas de réponse thierry ça
vous fait plaisir
oui je partirai pas en vacances avec lui
donc tout va bien jean-luc à une
question pour rome alors nous sommes
tous échoués sur une île déserte
pour survivre il faut manger un
chroniqueur qui propose plus et surtout
pourquoi qu'ils mangent et pourquoi pas
moi
alors toi jean luc non ouais toi parce
que on sait que c'est pas le gras qui
est bon c'est le muscle et notamment
d'un poulet tout c'est le muscle est
très quand même assez assez musclée en
tous les cas plus que tes petits
camarades en l'occurrence gilou thierry
où les autres qu'ils sont pas tellement
donc je pense que c'est un bon choix
d'accord très bien non mais c'est pas
pour l'instant hier il répond bien enfin
il vient comme dire dire qu'ils allaient
le bouffer
isabelle vous avez une question pour
mathieu oui si tu me veux tu que oumou
ou intelligent qu'est-ce que tu
choisirais abu beaucoup plus utile
[Applaudissements]
oslo je crois qu'on aime question dans
le public on a une personne de lui qu'il
faut poser une question oui c'est la
jeune fille tient ma chérie guingamp
boire bien on va regarder
voilà merci merci comment tu t'appelles
ma chérie bas il va ça va comment se la
pète d'un calage ma chérie 18 ans 18 ans
ça va coûter à ba mathieu oui telle
question pour lui va signer six des huit
prenait feu qui choisirais-tu en premier
et nora ou cyril pour le sauver a pour
le sauver ouais
oui alors en vue ce n'est pas là mais
non je dirais sans hésiter cyril 1 parce
que je l'adorent 2 parce qu'il me fait
vivre
vous avez dit à l'instant que vous
pouvez venir gratuitement
ben non mais je vais venir gratuitement
d'accord mais bon quand même si je
traite de l'être même mes productions
vous donner un petit coup de main voilà
je dis pas tout quand même
voilà deux passes qui me fait vivre et 3
parce que parce que c'est sans doute une
de mes plus belles rencontres de ces
cinq dernières années
[Applaudissements]
attention on a une question en vidéo
d'un plus d'un de vos plus grands fans à
regarder ça lui mathieu à 42 ans tu n'as
aucune ride avec une traction du sourcil
génétiquement impossible
aurais-tu recours à la toxine botulique
tel karen cheryl alors non pas pour le
moment mais je dit pas jamais d'autant
que lui veut absolument m'y emmener donc
j'ai promis que si un jour je devais
gérer avec lui mais ce qui me fait peur
c'est que lui en revanche l'a fait une
fois il arrivait sur le mag et il avait
un sourcil qui étaient restés bloqués je
jure que c'est vrai c'est dur après
trois semaines est quand même assez
paniquer
raymond domenech s'est lui est arrivé à
l'âge de 20 ans les deux sociétés
toujours y est toujours là raymond
toujours là toujours là on a une petite
question du patron des beats xavier
gandon 12 entre 12 ans regarde bonsoir
mathieu si je te demande est là tout de
suite de prendre la tête de tpm paie à
la place de cyril est ce que tu
accepterais vont rassure toi c'est pas
près d'arriver
alors je mens jamais un génie
franchement ça serait très flatteur mais
non jamais je le ferai et même si c'est
pas arrivé on me proposait les vendredis
ou quoi je dirais non parce que je je je
me sentirais pas à l'aise très bien où
mathieu pourtant vous aurez les
capacités de le faire je vous le dis non
je crois pas faire autre chose avec nous
c'est sûr quelqu'un qui vous connaît
très bien a tenu à vous poser une
question et lamont mathieu je pense que
vous allez être ému vous allez voir la
personne de votre mère salut ma tête
j'ai une question pour toi
à 26 ans tu as quitté ton boulot ton
boulot dans la finance et ce jour là tu
es déjeuner avec moi pas est ce que tu
te souviens précisément de ce que tu lui
as dit alors c'est votre frère donc
c'est mon frère guillaume way qui est
actuellement à los angeles
voilà et avec qui j'ai vécu quand il
était tout petit encore juste avant de
partir au canada est vraiment très chaud
il fait de la musique c'est mignon sais
pas comment vole bas mon père je lui ai
dit la vérité il pensait que j'allais
partir à londres
faire de la finance il était très très
fier ce conte une famille un peu
bourgeoise et je lui ai dit que
j'arrêtais tout et qu'il fallait bien
que je bouffe alors que j'allais devenir
serveur et je vais pas vous cacher que
ok c'est tout fait regardez on allende à
la réponse de votre frère a alors ce que
tu as répondu c'est ya dix ans j'ai fait
des études pour te faire plaisir
aujourd'hui j'ai démissionné pour me
faire plaisir
et voilà ça c'était le début de grandes
choses pour toi et je suis très fière de
toi je pense à je pense à toi tout le
temps ton petit frère qui t'aime
vous devez regarder les filles oui il
est vraiment beau ça qu'il est bon un
très beau très beau très sympa on a une
question une question d'un très bon ami
à vous dans le métier aussi regardent
bonsoir mathieu tu as dis donc
en prime time sur des huit que tu avais
déjà coucher pour réussir
tiens donc mathieu avez vous déjà
coucher pour réussir
oui vérité donc mathieu carrément
honnêteté douche je le savoir avec qui
merde alors mathieu mathieu c'est
marc-olivier fogiel qui vous a posé la
question
mathieu vous allez nous répondre dans un
instant mathieu ouest avec nous je
passerai sur le détecteur de mensonges
et il y aura la première partie des
questions en 4/3 de jean luc lemoine a
tout de suite journée là on est en
direct dans l'instant il y aura les
questions 4/3 de jean luc lemoine une
première fournée et je peux vous dire
qu'il a du très très lourd ce soir et
laura est revenue bravo aux noix
et matthieu delormeau et sur la chaise
alors et n'aura peut-être que vous avez
loupé la question de marc olivier fogiel
à c'était quoi à matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau
vous avez le droit votre joker si vous
appuyez sur le buzzer il y aura un joker
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
regardez la question qu'a posée marc
olivier fogiel à mathieu de l'andrh bon
sens mathieu tu as dis donc
en prime time sur des huit que tu avais
déjà coucher pour réussir
tiens donc mathieu avez vous déjà
coucher pour réussir
oui vérité donc monsieur carrément
honnêteté de le savoir avec qui alors
mathieu vous pouvez prendre le joker que
je sais rien j'ai bien fait de revenir
inutile vous ai jamais menti
là j'ai dit toute la vérité pour non non
non mais je vais pas mettre quelqu'un en
porte à faux
non mais on s'en fout
qu'est ce qu'il est dit moi ça m'arrange
pas parce que je veux c'est marco qui
est posé la question mais j'entends
c'est vaincre amis oui mon ami aussi
j'aime beaucoup de mon frère si votre
frère ah oui alors je réponds tu sais
pas si je suis prêt mais sans rigoler
c'est vrai c'est comme moi là on arrive
devant une fille on se met tous nus pour
0 est pas prêt je suis pas prêt je fais
pas peut-être c'est mieux pourquoi ben
non sinon vous appuyer non mais vous
voulez le garder avec si vous voulez
mais j'ai peur que vous soyez déçu par
la réponse c'est oui
ouais bah si je suis déçu ça va je fais
beaucoup moins dramatique que fouras ce
qu'est aujourd'hui j'entends mal
[Rires]
si vous le faites pas pour moi fait le
bois pour jean-luc non mais c'est pour
ça j'ai peur vous soyez déçu mais donc
je vais répondre à marc-olivier
qu'ignorait la réponse est donc aux
téléspectateurs aussi absolument j'ai
une fois dans ma vie coucher pour
réussir
je reconnais avec une femme qui était
professeur à la faculté en comptabilité
et c'était au canada et je devais
absolument réussir secours pour ensuite
pouvoir avant mon diplôme et je l'avais
fait déjà une fois une deuxième fois et
j'avais raté et j'ai bien vu qu'on
accrochait un peu qu elle me regardait à
la fac alors que moi je m'en foutais et
donc gelé un peu draguer prénom horrible
elles apprennent aux rimes elle
s'appelait rhône et rhône et je vous
jure
ah ouais elle m'a présenté sa famille
mais raison je suis déçu
[Applaudissements]
et donc j'ai couché avec elle à eau
[Musique]
j'étais déçu
[Applaudissements]
ça ça c'est tout ça ce dépôt faire
parler les babas il peut toujours qui
est des nouilles dans une séquence est
matthieu delormeau tisot batteux de
langon rouzède large en matière de la
gare dont mathieu vient de cyril da
rocha bravo chéri mathieu de l'arbre
endroit tenu secret
oui nous poser nos questions
oui nous poser toutes vos questions les
chéris puisque dans un instant je
passerai sur le détecteur de mensonges
oui je vous le dis il ya notre ami le
gars du fbi ayew et là je vous dis il
est à fond dedans et pour le moment
première partie des questions quatre
pierres de jean luc lemoine c'est parti
alors jean luc est ce qu'on peut dire
que ce sont les quatre tiers de la
vérité ah oui et là c'était vraiment une
thématique et ce soir je vais répéter
des choses et notamment quelque chose à
la deuxième partie a pour ce que vous
imaginez même pas aller si jean-luc moi
je vous attends je vous aime et vous
savez que je vous ai jamais autant aimé
que ce soir soirée fertile et
jean-michel ça fait trois jours qui
essaie aussi de faire de la lèche à toi
tu est une question bonjour monsieur
lemoine je rappelle denise je vous aime
beaucoup mais depuis quelques temps je
trouve que vous devenez une couille
molle
est ce que vous allez enfin dire toute
la vérité sur les chroniqueurs
[Rires]
elle est drôle
en tout cas je vois quel bout connaît
bien vous êtes sûr de ce que vous avez
déjà d'or wisher denise en tout cas ce
soir je vais tout vous dire tout est
secret et où les relations entre
chroniqueurs toutes les tensions les
passions ce soir vous saurez tout déjà
il faut savoir que le sol ne touche pas
à mon poste le ciment c'est l'admiration
que vous tous les chroniqueurs à cyril
qui déplace les foules comme personne
c'est un leader né le che guevara de
tunis est coupée même quand il finit pas
ses phrases les gens l'adorent
mais j'en fait que les gens me voient
prudent
nous là je ne savais pas si fou fait
remarquer ce halo 3 par les drones les
goûts
le public et merci à vous et juste
indulgent merci à vous merci merci à
voir également chez vous j'adorais le il
est trop bas c'est fou mais c'est bien
la preuve que pour nous cyril en fait
passer la lumière c'est la lumière alors
la question qu'on peut évidemment se
poser c'est où se nichent sa force est
bien partout s'il crée en permanence et
son vrai plaisir c'est d'inventer des
chansons pour ses chroniqueurs l'adoré
là il va partir sur valérie bénaïm comme
ça en impro ses traits impression de
voir un génie créé car très vite il va
se rend compte que peu de choses rime
avec benhaim ses bras portent des
agences d'intérim
alors comment va-t-il s'en sortir tout
de suite une leçon
ben laden adela mbnl et naïm benaïm ou
frigide benali mon voeu qu un jeune
héros doit ça passe toujours ça passe
mais reste sympa mais ça passe toujours
et ça ne rime pas mais ça passe ici
beinheim remake on te bouffe le cul
c'est évident comme ça mais une fois
qu'on le dit alors plus fort en même que
siri d'une façon y'a pas même s'il a des
challengers dans l'équipe
là on cherchait une rime avec moctar qui
malheureusement est déjà parti mokhtar
mokhtar le tartare mokhtar le tartare
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà à chaque fois que je montre
ça jean michel regrette et après
recommence c'est son problème
je vais tout vous montrer
je vais tout vous dire sur les vrais
rapports entre les chroniqueurs déjà il
ya une belle solidarité
regardez valérie bénaïm quand un de ses
camarades se casse la gueule à côté
d'elle enfin c'est remarquable parce
qu'en fait elle fait rien non plus au
mieux les dénoncer aux manettes pas mais
je suis pas là dedans regardez regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
des clips dix familles alors dressé
l'anniversaire de l'un de nos ébats
c'est la fête très serré mais il y en a
une autre qui fêtait son anniversaire
c'est éric camous leeuw a dit vous
verrez que vous mettiez votre 34 ans est
bien parce que y'a pas un mec de
l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien je vous avoue éric assez
particulier on les aime bien arrosée
mena on la comprend pas toujours
non mais parfois et part dans des
explications lunaire on n'arrive pas à
suivre
là vous allez voir sans raison
particulière et nous parler de s'assurer
dans un escape game
regardez là tu corriges basse je ne sais
pas si vous avez vu était dur on en
passe tout le monde est magique mais mon
préféré c'est gilles verdez lui il est
carrément paniqué j'ai fait mais cette
dernière c'est génial ça me fait penser
à ça c'est à dire qu'on tend vers la
culture du jury je vous en rêvez à cirer
cintres de fous vous attend une pièce
vous avez vous avez 60 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les sages du fouta le gard mais son père
d'anissa du soutien genre mais petit
quelque chose
il est à tort il était même c'est bon là
qu'on l'ait mal à halen singularité et
que ce soit comme tous ici d'ailleurs
voilà vous avez tous une singularité
entend plus que d'autres voilà oui mais
c'est normal il faut s'habituer
titi et jean-michel par exemple ça fait
longtemps qu'ils se connaissent donc ils
sont très complices presque trop non
mais franchement je regardais un petit
peu dans le rétroviseur ils ont beaucoup
évolué depuis le début de touche pas à
mon poste là pour un débat on avait
distribué des pancartes avec des têtes
de présentateurs de jt
bonjour
les to b
[Musique]
ouais quand même et ça la saison ça
détend savonnez temps quand on voit ça
on aimerait bien que jean-michel repas
de couvrir un conflit quand même la
personne et brion la meilleure
intervention de jean michel du mois
complet a fallu ce malus malus malus
après ils s'étonnent que je monte
voilages expliquant même cyril parler
latin et demander les mots que les
chroniqueurs que je connais c'est ce qui
nous a mené à cette belle réflexion de
notre champion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane bern présenté par jour monsieur
le maire a baissé mes secrets d'histoire
veux pas parce qu'on a perdu des autres
mais touche pas mon choix c'est aussi un
esprit de cohésion facile vous souvenez
de l'émission spéciale koh lanta et bas
lors de cette édition il y avait deux
équipes
aouita nas lra sera os et à la pause le
producteur nourdine était venu voir
chaque équipe pour le demander de
trouver un cri de guerre ne pouvait pas
résister au plaisir de volonté ce
brillant brainstorming
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il nous faut travailler plus fort
allemagne en nous unissant les oraisons
d'avoir le bonheur expansif parce que
une minute plus tard avec la nation lors
et dans las
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la déception est on est on est les rats
trail ou non vous êtes l'état lâche
alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
voilà et l'autre et hello alone qui ne
se démonte jamais joué pour moi je les
vois dépité je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai
dit voilà je reviens à ma place
tranquille série leur dois je me dis mon
nom je leur dis non et en fait à oui
vous avez bien possible et très déçu ce
côté là bon après je vous refais pas
toutes les missions mais à un moment
l'état n'a sans doute éliminer des rats
sera et bien comme c'est le prime de la
vérité je dois te dire si et n'aura été
sauvées et ben c'est grâce à mathieu
j'ai l'impression d'être au conseil de
koh lanta il ya une tension en gare de
la maine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y'a pire d'ailleurs je dois voir toute
la longueur de la ned qui m'avait fait
pour hrw est bio suis juste cette scène
ce que j'ai à me dire vous défendez pas
d'armé et n'aura il vous a sauvé parce
qu'il vous aime
on s'en fout de la taille des gens pour
penser le talent il a raison il dit la
raison mathieu aime beaucoup et n'aura
pas bien alors quand il s'agit de
définir notre pile but breton à celui
qui en parle le mieux est basse et
matthieu allard si on te le dire tu es
dépendante de conneries mais ça va mal
et dont on connaît déjà les trois noms
mais excuse moi il m'a engueulé parce
que j'étais un homme banon mais mon
corps et ma faute
samedi en sapin quoi tu me semble aller
bien
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas possible
la boule adoré impôts j'adore mais c'est
un pote c'est un poteau avec des nichons
bon ça c'était l'époque où mathieu
n'était pas encore capricieux et oui ça
essayez là où on disait de s'asseoir à
maintenant c'est fini
s'il n'a pas sa place il boude regardez
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est nouveau ce petit essai lundi 8
heures il faut savoir la place de
mathieu c'est là à côté de valérie
bénaïm et ça pour valérie c'est un gros
coup dur parce que mathieu comment dire
il est gentil il comprend tout très vite
mais il faut lui expliquer longtemps
par exemple depuis le début de l'année
est perçu que valérie et arabes maroc
obligatoirement elle a dû investir dans
un restaurant de couscous pour lui c'est
qu'au maintien une idée en tête
vous allez voir au bout d'un moment même
si c'est très difficile de le faire
sortir de ses gonds
on sent que valérie on a vraiment ras le
bol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma rue
l'important pour plusieurs c'est vrai
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
voilà pour que vous sachiez merguez
boulette tout ça c'est là là ça n'a rien
à voir c'est hachis parmentier voilà
tant qu 20 bat et là tout ça d'accord
mais là vous avez vous êtes entre les
deux d'accord vous êtes entre la merguez
et le pois chiche ça me va mon gsm et il
va y avait toujours dans les rapports
entre chroniqueurs il faut savoir que
dans l'équipe on a un avis très arrêtées
sur le physique de ses collègues
bisous
la musique
gentil avec cela
non
ah bon sens lui qui dès aujourd'hui il
ya d'autres choses qui arrivent dans la
tente jaune il ya plein de choses et
vous aurez une énorme révélation fut
même pas de quoi il s'agit
ça sera dans la deuxième partie mais
énorme énorme vraiment ah ouais je vous
avais dit surpris et jolie et ya gilles
verdez on a une surprise pour lui et
vous a préparé quelque chose parce que
vous allez voir une surprise pour vous
oui vous verrez il y aura le frère de
gilles bérard qui viendra nous voir car
un instant sur des vite et ils ont
préparé un numéro avec des poils et le
frère de gilles verdez vous le
connaissez a tout de suite sur des huit
suites des carrières on est en direct
sur des 8 et jean luc lemoine va
continuer ces questions enquête hier
dans un instant juste après je vais
passer au détecteur de mensonges
gilles verdez vous allez quitter la
salle puisque vous ne vous avez pris par
un très beau spectacle avec votre frère
absolument
votre frère on va dévoiler de qui s'agit
dans un instant et puis y'a mokhtar qui
nous a rejoints car maintenant on a fait
venir sa maman et ses deux soeurs de
tunisie et je voudrais dire il est venu
me voir il est il est comme un fou pour
les ai fait venir donc je suis très très
heureux d'évoluer parce que c'est le
frérot il sait comme je lai mokhtar
aussi un peu plus le plaisir franchement
bon bah c'est bon il a pas envie de voir
ça le connaît
il est comme moi on est de la même école
on n'aime pas hamon mokhtar vrai nom
mais moi je suis né à oui c'est mon
frérot comme tu es content mon chéri
très content merci encore à tous les
endroits sera fort et façon la route
attendant il servait à trop manger tous
les chiffres
ça me fait vraiment plaisir de faire
plaisir plaisir alors avant de mokhtar
et à ses deux soeurs alors mon jean luc
on a on a des doses on a des noces moins
réjouissant pour l'équipe oh ça se passe
bien alors on est et on s'était quittés
sur une aura qui parle est difficile de
tirer mais roubaix alors c'est un peu
méchant mais c'est aussi cette franchise
qui fait la force de l'émission on est
différent dans l'équipe et on l'assument
par exemple on n'a pas les mêmes goûts
au niveau musical et nos isabelle qu'on
leur passe de lou bega belle soit en
france elise la belle aime bien partager
ses passions avec moi par exemple
moi c'est plus de 10 bon en même temps
et toutes les musiques
tant qu'elle peut bouger son corps donc
pour rendre hommage à cette grande
créatrice un nouveau numéro de danse de
vos biens on adore
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça paie
comment
[Musique]
contrat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à propos des transports
à cela les gars savent garder avance est
très habile bravo bravo à vous mais je
le disais le vrai lyon l'émission bat
cécile 5 et 6 créatif bout un objet il
imagine un peu ning tout de suite lors
de la spéciale top chef y avait une
carotte devant lui où là aussi matthieu
delormeau en ont offert comme un peu
ning matthieu delormeau carottes non je
voulais c'est dans la continuité car
vous allez voir la carotte a beaucoup
voyagé à mon avis y en a qui va avoir
une surprise en voyant ces images non au
monde
enfin les coudes tamaya
on regarde
comment
oh [ __ ] c'est goûteux commun qui nous
unit tous enfin c'est qu'à chaque
interview perso on nous demande de
parler de la bande de l'émission de
celui qu'on appelle hanouna legrand ou
cyril le majestueux la dernière s'y est
collé ses essais et nora dans le buzz
tva avec beaucoup de brio
si vous l'avez manqué j'ai interview que
j'ai un peu améliorée car quitte à de
préciser illustrer ses propos avec des
exemples vous compreniez ce qui se passe
vraiment dans notre équipe
tpm paix on en parle 1 instance a
démarré très fort il ya même un record à
plus de 1,9 million de téléspectateurs
la barrière des 2 millions d'e mails
encore une folie death comment vous
expliquer ce succès voilà dix ans cyril
hanouna que vous vous dites un phare
dans la nuit
[Applaudissements]
with a écarté les eaux et là il est
vraiment il écarte pas je sais pas quoi
vous dire
faut pas que tu restes là sinon on va
facturer cela si on va te bouffer le cul
c'est quoi la mayonnaise au delà de
three neymar on s'entend tous tellement
bien
[Applaudissements]
windows peut-on tirer du côté des
immeubles
[Musique]
une famille
on se connaît maintenant depuis plus de
six ans on est amis dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
et puis la matière noire manquait quand
même le petit dernier qui est arrivé
dans cette bande comme si on connaissait
depuis 15 ans qui a trouvé une place
tout de suite
[Musique]
qui a trouvé une place tout de suite
cohérente
cohérente et pertinente
[Applaudissements]
et tout cela rondement menée par cyril
[Musique]
des chroniqueurs formidable valérie
bénaïm isabelle gsid les filles
forcément jean-luc le taulier
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi vous dire tout
fonctionne ça arrive pas ça frédéric
taddeï beau faire il a vraiment perdu
des clés aux gardes
c'est une équipe quand même de qualité
et puis cyril en producteur qui vraiment
tous les jours se remet en question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
alors
soyez heureux ça n'est que la première
partie des quatre titres j'ai passé au
détecteur de mensonges et gilles verdez
banon faire son petit numéro et on
retrouvera jean luc et jean luc vous
avez une révélation incroyable à nous
faire ch
ouais ouais ouais vraiment vraiment vous
surprendre vraiment vraiment abbas et
prem de la vérité c'était aujourd'hui ou
jamais alors jean luc reste à côté moi
parce que vous allez reprendre dans
l'instant on n'est même pas besoin de
retourner à votre place avant que je
passe sur le détecteur de mensonges on
va avoir notre ami un qui va venir nous
voir c'est d'ailleurs jean-luc qui va
qui va animer la séquence il ya
quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup
quelqu'un qu'on avait vu dans c'est mon
choix est-ce que vous rappelez de la
personne qu'on a vu dans ces bons choix
oui non tenir son assemblée le nul liste
le nudiste qui ressemblent à des
responsales extra au régime et chérie
oui ça s'apprend faut que je le regarde
[Applaudissements]
on
ils vont me fait trop rire parce que
vous vous auriez pu faire une autre
émission qu'on adore faire un c'est mon
choix que vous ressemblez tellement agi
claire days le chroniqueur de cyril
hanouna que peut-être vous ne connaissez
pas ou peu que vous ne regardez pas la
télévision suppose effectivement je
regarde assez peu la balle est
actuellement
[Applaudissements]
gilbert gress venir se [ __ ] à poil
sont associés mon choix c'est quand yves
alors je veux remercier les ied une
comme à bâtir et pollen fort mais c'est
pas gilles qui est allé sur le plateau
de c'est mon choix c'est son frère qui
l'a rejoint ici sur le plateau et oui
est ce qu'on les à jérôme revon gilles
verdez et et est notre ami si au ps
qu'on peut pas ce qu'on peut les voir
s'il vous plaît ce qu'on peut les voir
parce qu'ils vont nous prépare un petit
numéro
non non c'est agir alors est ce que
c'est juste ça ou pas non non c'est bien
garni je me sens opposé alors je la
chante trop musclée ça dépasse pas c'est
quand je sors je sens que toutes les
femmes sont en train de frétiller parce
qu'ils nous ont préparé un show
incroyable avec des poils des poêles à
poil pour vos hérisser les poils c'est
jean luc reichmann et petite beauté
attention regardez d'abord c'est parti
[Musique]
on casse tapantes
[Applaudissements]
m
mais en bas les mains
passons
au départ les mains sauf les mecs ça
paie pas les mains
balmain
ces malfaçons aladin
un serpent minuit
[Musique]
me wade
attention la piste les yeux sont rivés
sur toi mes amis qui épris d'elle
[Musique]
à
pas
m
[Musique]
samedi
ouais
tél
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ap comme ça marche
ap
[Musique]
on a tenu
moi
si vous nous rejoignez sûr de lui
c'est le braille spécial vérité hausse
aspirons à new york au lavis ils ont
bien voulu cerexhe et bonne humeur ont
franchement vient des jumelles enlevées
aux exilés formidable églises et nos
gens nos plateaux dans un instant mais
là c'est le roi qui va reprendre la main
parce que les questions qu'elle tiers
sahara pendant un instant et je vais
donc passer au détecteur de mensonges
avec notre ami jour lucas voilà non même
kelly norman kali norman norman bonsoir
bonsoir je vais donc passer le détecteur
d'invention jean-luc vous avez des
questions les chroniqueurs les personnes
sur twitter des téléspectateurs je
m'assois with the soit je vais vous
mettre les comprimés mais toujours là
sera donc normal vous allez passer
cyril à l'interrogatoire il ne pourra
pas mentir on avoir besoin sur célé
contre monsieur quelqu'un qui triche
vous allez devoir être assis dessus en
alsace en enlever pas donc là je fais
quoi là fait simplement vous asseoir à
ce sujet d'accord j'ai couvert savoir si
vous trichez les deux fesses ou les deux
savoie correct je rappelle que norman
kelly est l'homme qui a fait avouer à
matthieu delormeau qu'ils portaient des
slips en cuir exclusif rouge
donc c'est pas n'importe quoi donc je
vais donner très drôle c'est que je
reçois encore des nouilles ah oui
j'aimerais donner la parole au public
aux chroniqueurs et aux twittos ce
qu'ils vont poser des questions à ses
rides on va commencer tout de suite
alors déjà il faut qu'ils installent des
composants mathieu à prêter quand j'ai
dit pas trop vous approcher un petit peu
vers moi quand vous mettez vous bien
comme ça on colle des coups d'approché
vos champions
non non non c'est cela que c'est cela
c'est qu'on veut mettre les concerts
collier à isabelle morini bosc
comment on relève la même chose pendant
la période de pause on court on oui
c'est toujours comme ça c'est comme ça
oui encore une seconde je me c'est comme
ça qu'ils feraient tout le temps mais
papa nantes est ce juste le temps de
mettre les composants pas d'accord faut
mettre les composantes ce combat tous
les composants ce que tous les mecs les
composantes la joc normal je vais les
nervis va dire que je mords chaque fois
non ce qui m'inquiète c'est que si on a
endommagé une composante vous allez
peut-être aussi pour un manteau tout au
long du finalement de l'épreuve ce
serait provient donc fait remettre
composantes ouais il faut bien les
mettre c'est ici c'est un bon d'accord
on se rappelle les consignes que je vous
ai donné vous reculez maintenant
d'accord le banc on met les autres
composants dieu bénisse les mocassins en
tout cas normal
[Applaudissements]
théo s'est passé chez schwab en devenir
c'est tout ce que j'ai pu me payer avec
le budget et barnabé données
[Applaudissements]
mais bon il est très bon la ville
travaille pour la vérité je vois là dire
également c'est vrai ja serge un sermon
doit là dedans oui ces poilus pas face
et mousseux non je mettrai pas de gel il
est bizarre
il a du canada pour noah oui vous dire
que c'est quelqu'un de très
professionnel
vous avez travaillé pour le s royal
canadien ouais la sûreté du québec
retiré la sûreté du québec et à lévis
avec la sortie à 13 l'a13 autour du
soleil
oui et aujourd'hui au privé simplement
peut être conseillé aux téléspectateurs
que l'émission n'est pas selon part et
les règles et les standards de tesco
lyrique un test normal et je cherche je
cherche beaucoup plus cher que ce que le
budget ne vous permet ici mais quand
même je suis heureuse ici sur le platine
en train de faire perdre aux avions
venant mais il est content de venir si
on l'entend les gens ici tous les jours
qui viennent une perte de l'audition
d'hier comme juillet pour la publicité
et on est prêt pas grave c'est ce que je
vous avais dit on reste mauvais tout au
long d'une ferme sa gueule je serai en
vie on respire on respire normalement et
on dit la vérité et on écoutait
directives si j'en éprouve est pas trop
j'ai 12,8 la dotation
je vais non ils vont commencer on peut y
aller pour les biens seront pas trop
vous me dites est ce qu'il faut que
j'aille serious et on peut attaquer
directement vous l'avez déjà testé
l'invention qu'un vous êtes prêt à vous
il a proféré j'avais important c'est
qu'il lui dise la vérité
on va voir tout de suite on va la vendre
à une question de chroniqueurs attendait
parce que je veux installer derrière
si je veux être en mesure d'analyser ces
réactions physiologiques
mais on attend des joueurs il n'est pas
bien sûr il sera tête de ma mère ça fait
quoi comme quand je mets des brassards
l'été
je lui mets pas aussi aux jeunes filles
brassard dora l'exploratrice gelé mais
aussi en jeune fille est ce que ça vous
vend jeune fils aymon fait je le kiffe
grave c est ce qu on peut y aller norman
les hits d'un dancing en fait à kandy
crush en plus alors j'ai voulu que vous
avez des questions que tout le monde
s'ils ont des questions tout le monde on
sait surtout tout le monde
toulon va pouvoir vous poser des
questions à commencer par les
chroniqueurs et quand normal me donnera
le top
vous me dites il ya des téléspectateurs
zioui exactement et il est détourné
suite au score
j'ai des questions que vous allez pas
sortir dès qu'il ya des cameramans des
cadreurs tout le monde même des gens qui
passent dans la rue
il va commencer par thierry moreau qui
est une question pour vous cyril on ne
bouge pas cyril si un jour je fais un
one man show est ce que vous viendrez me
voir non
ça ça veut dire qu'il a dit la vérité il
n'ira pas oui
[Applaudissements]
séduits mon préféré en même temps même
sur des décors je vais le dire non mais
juge devrait dire j'aime ce mec ça comme
ça est une erreur pour une question de
valérie bénaïm votre ami louis cyrille
est ce que parmi toutes tes chroniqueuse
tu as une préférée of s'envole balle est
limité oui oui il a une préférée est-ce
que tu as une deuxième question valérie
oui est ce que par exemple ce serait une
brune
oui bon je croise les doigts merci oui
pouvez-vous répéter la question s'il
vous plaît semblerait qu'ils n'ont pas
ce qu'est ce que c'est est ce que par
exemple ce serait une brune oui
désolé n'aura labat yeux de leurs mots
six compères mais je sais tu es de leurs
maux ben justement elle et matthieu
delormeau pour se venger
excusez moi c'est pas prêt mais ce que
je peux imposer 2 vas-y doucement de la
crise ont eu déjà alors une première
cyril est ce que certains chroniqueurs
gagne le double des autres
[Rires]
oui oh [ __ ] aimerait ça à [ __ ] la
merde ce soir
[Applaudissements]
le trip de près normal 0 ont fait pas de
commentaire non plus faire ou alors il
m'a tuer il avait une deuxième question
allait accorder sa plus personnelle même
si la première may jagger h est quand
même parce que c'est pas moi le double
cyril hatt eu oui ou non des sentiments
pour moi
non non amoureuse
[Applaudissements]
encore du boulot le moment le plus drôle
de l'émission c'est normal qu'ils mois
garde fait chaud gars je suis obligé de
dire la vérité
oui c'est pour ça qu'il est resté
finalement jean michel est une question
si pour toi cyril jeunechamp passe à la
cire il honnêtement est-ce que tu
trouves que tu as un gros zizis n'ont
pas bougé il faut pas bouger est bon
alors on va prendre la question après
avoir par la question ce qu'elle était
bien la raison lambada
c'est vrai qu'il ya la question de
bouger prenez gaulle le gars il a
travaillé que le fbi a et où vous voyez
en interrogatoire ce que vous pensiez
que le coupable un grossiste l'activité
sexuelle est légal ça peut être
important parce que j'avais envie
d'avoir tremblay alors jean-michel alors
sert il selon toi est ce que tu vois un
gros zizi oui
[Applaudissements]
pour considérer qu'un caractère
subjectif à la question ces peines
certains clients c'est cela sa route et
je compare ça c'est pas grave mon coeur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une question sérieuse
cyril quand tu gardé tous les
chroniqueurs la saison prochaine oui oui
un mensonge mensonge y est
[Applaudissements]
et je rajouterais comme l'a dit la
presse ils partiront demain
j'ai posé une question de tweets et les
tutos ce qui nous envoyait déjà qu'on
ira sur et nora est sûre et nora berra
yasar mokhtar une question si la belle
est roi trépanier sur mokhtar juin alors
marie qui demande cyril et tu es
amoureux de valérie dit la vérité parce
que ça se voie trop non
à celle avalée il n'est pas amoureux de
valérie question karen dans de marie
amélie serait ce possible que mathieu et
anime l'émission juste une fois non
[Rires]
il va faire d'autres choses si c'est
possible pour peut-être c'est possible
trop tard cependant le mal est fait et
il ne veut pas je vous jure que c'est
vrai il ne veut pas s que bob tahri qui
suit à ce que pendant toutes ces
émissions pas t'as déjà envie moi je
vois là on l'a fait devait devenir un
invité alors la question votre temps en
gros moteur je pense qu'il veut savoir
si à pendant l'émission vous avez déjà
eu envie de virer un invité lancé
jean-luc
oui oui j'aimerais bien pourquoi je veux
dire pourquoi c'est parce que j'ai été
très malade et que j'avais très mal au
ventre a c'est à dire on a compris et
nora une question cyril à part dans le
vert d'isabelle morini bornant à avez
vous déjà trompé votre zizi dans un
autre verre d'un autre chroniqueur qui
ne seraient pas au courant
[Rires]
oui donc j'ai une deuxième question
évidemment
il ya des vérités on n'aimerait pas les
aborder calvaire c'est un comble et le
verre qu'elle saisit enfin qu'elle
visite dans quelques chroniqueurs
auquel vert de quelques chroniques en
avez vous trempez votre je peux pas je
dois répondre que par oui ou par non ah
oui et ce serait trop long de faire tous
les chroniqueurs mal aux questions du
public peut être celui celui sur en tout
cas celui qui a bu le verre est immunisé
contre la maladie c'est kaka qu'il ait
jamais malade
jean-michel une question du public pour
cyril à lire il
pourrais-tu battre un jour au ping-pong
stéphane plaza art pourrais-tu te battre
au ping pong stéphane plaza oui une
dernière question du public
est ce que comme mathieu tu as déjà
porter un slip rouge exclusif wii
ça devient flippant cet interrogatoire
je crois qu'on va finir si vous êtes
d'accord par une question d'un autre de
téléspectateurs au téléphone avec les
dents on y va aussi est-ce que vous
m'entendez vous m'entendez au téléphone
allô allô pas bonsoir
à la haye la la c'est une meuf
normalement elle appelle toute une
histoire en anonyme normalement comment
vous appeler madame bonsoir bonsoir à
vous appeler bonsoir barbara dont sur
moi par un ça va
elle a dit pas madame
quant à votre prénom s'cusez moi madame
vous êtes vous attendez pression et
c'est quoi votre prénom
assez d'accord
[ __ ] c'est ma mère en tant que
septième match de leur volume a donné
des numéros
visiblement tu l'appelles sourds tulard
connaît bien
enfin ça ça ou d'y aller alors alors
esther vous avez une question pour votre
fils j'aime pas les bouley on vous
écoute
pire il a écrit sur des tons choix pour
ce mariage avec camille oui vous aiderez
côté il faut que ça brille pas tu dis si
c'est la vega et regarde qui vient du
canada à le faire pour que ça marche il
faut que siri est temps de répondre je
vous laisse reprendre la question et
aller au bout de votre question me tuent
leurs pasteurs sétois n'ont pas paille
d'or ouais je connais fracasse alors
vous écoutez ce n'est pas du tout à la
lire il est question de ton choix pour
ce mariage avec camille mais pourquoi
vous vous êtes sa question
ac et de lormont c'est un amoureux
transi ou en gros
j'ai l'impression que pour votre maman
son coeur balance entre camille et
mathieu aimerait savoir si vous êtes sûr
de votre amour pour camille ils
balancent pas ton coeur la banane avant
l'humain est oui alors aucune chance
pour deux ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci à six mois
persil pas bah voilà ça c'est fait on a
une bonne question d'isabelle morini
basma isabelle isabelle elle est super
complémentaires vers la question de
votre maman puisque est ce que le
mariage de las vegas entre vous et
camille va-t-il vraiment être consommés
d'une d'une façon ou d'une autre
face à tous d'une façon non non si tu
mets mensonges sur la tête de ma mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a mal excellent merci mes chéris et
bravo à aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'un jour le brestois aussi
désagréable désagrège merci mort
mannequins élite les formules ab qui
refera d'euros de prime avait plus ou
moins
jean lui jean-luc on continue les
cafetières doigts et ben oui y'a des
quatre fers et il a une énorme
révélation à nous faire jean luc lemoine
merci normal d'avoir été lésé l'air si
normal jean luc lemoine et les
cafetières continue et ça te rester deux
heures assis sur le fauteuil
non mr questions merci norman qui
reprend ses petites affaires un
tranquille merci d'or bat attention mon
jean luc d'autres choses puisque les
quatre sièges reviennent on a une autre
question en fait ouais et la question
pour démarrer c'est parti bonjour je
m'appelle corinne est il vrai que les
gens qui conçoivent touche pas à mon
poste sont exclusivement recrutés aux
alcooliques anonymes
c'est une excellente question chars
corinne oui c'est vrai mais mais pas que
touche pas à mon poste une vraie
mécanique de précision
il ya bien évidemment les chroniqueurs
que vous voyez à l'antenne ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon technique les
feignasses et puis il ya tous les autres
ceux qui bossent vraiment il ya déjà
l'équipe rédactionnelle avec notamment
le rédacteur en chef adjoint romain en
gros qui à chaque pub vient classer les
fiches et faire un point avec series sur
le bon déroulement de l'émission
alors vous allez voir la conversation
est un peu technique mais c'est
intéressant car ce explique sans doute
pourquoi touche pas à mon poste et le
premier talk show du soir
[Musique]
ça va ton cul ça va
elle a dit avoir bien joué
[Applaudissements]
votre formule a fait un amour merci de
nous
moi je suis venu il y avait la lumière
c'était comme ça non plus très
honnêtement j'ai rencontré un garçon
adorable mais c'est génial de vénérables
cette magnifique les deux dit merci
d'être là vous êtes vraiment un amour
merci beaucoup
il est bleu nature idée on développe
naturisme oui je suis d'accord
aujourd'hui qu'on adopte sectionnait bdc
ça mais enfin vous rigolez leur façon de
bosser mais c'est très important le
travail de romain carcan syrien n'a plus
ses fiches
il est perdu mais comme c'est un génie
et retombe toujours sur ses pattes
alors vous allez voir c'est très simple
quand cyril ne sais pas quoi dire il
fait une réclamation
alors là là là c'est cholet ils m'ont
enlevé toutes mes fiches ces connards
mais les anciennes je les ai pas à
couilles molles
là
[Applaudissements]
ça passe ça passe ça passe
les sens de l'à-propos quand même un
trait sur plateau ya aussi les amis de
cyril qui ne sont pas payés mais qui se
relaient chaque jour à son chevet ils
sont très importants car quand notre
chef à parler boulot avec son équipe
rédactionnelle
ça lui permet de penser autre chose
avant le retour à l'antenne regardez ça
bah ouais rien elle est belle couilles
way a bien manié crypte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette deuxième chercheurs des quatre
on a un petit peu épicée tout ça quand
même
la deuxième partie succès des missions
il ya bien évidemment éric notre cas on
ne sait si bien motivé votre public et
avec mon chéri voilà même si
objectivement quand c'est julien courbet
qui présente
il fait un peu moins d'efforts que pour
cyril
[Applaudissements]
réagissez
une autre [ __ ] qui nourrit même si
c'est pas ça je tiens à dire de kadir il
dit ça tous les jours de la semaine
c'est vrai ou pas bon oeil il dit ça
tous les jours de la semaine c'est sa
phrase voilà c'est la phrase qui équipe
le plus au monde
le leader du mal mais aussi les
techniciens et les régisseurs qui se
démène pour satisfaire cyril là pour la
venue de cristina cordula notre maître
avait voulu un podium de défilé
c'était très joli mais comme c'est
exceptionnel à la fin de l'émission
isabelle morini bosc avait oublié qu'il
y en avait un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
très fort j'aime bien la compassion de
matthieu mais on a eu très peur on a cru
qu'elle avait cassé le podium et comme
c'était de la location isabelle qui
l'une des chroniqueuses les plus
appréciés dans notre public a oui et
vous savez pourquoi
et ben parce que elle elle est toujours
très soucieuses de leur confort à notre
public est très puissant ils ont tous le
public a souvent on va vous souffler
dessus les uns après les autres
bon on va vous frottez sinon vous
frottez vous les uns les autres tâches
et autres
elle n'est pas possible mais ce succès
vient aussi de cette vente si fourni le
problème c'est que ces grandes bouches
c'est très compliqué de prendre la
parole d'habitude
isabelle qui galèrent pas mal mais lors
d'une émission elle avait échangé sa
place contre la neige pas si vous
souffrez je me rappelle est bien
l'aspect dit que tout serait plus simple
pour se faire remarquer je vais pas vous
mentir ça n'a pas bien marché on disait
à l'époque de marianne james et manu
katché c'est pire que ça oui vous disais
ça manquait justement on reprochait the
voice qu'être des trop lisse et vous
disent risque est bien c'est que se
[ __ ] de la gueule des candidats et qui
sont un peu durs pourraient savoir avait
changé d'avis tout des semaines à moins
détruit dans l'angle mort laruns
[Rires]
elle est géniale je vois sur un isabelle
n'est pas la seule à galérer les invités
aussi galère sauf que il insiste moins
regardée de virginie efira sur la gauche
on a gardé le même temps oublié la
dédicace à ta mère à cdg raconté intrus
tout d'abord il s'est dit je vais
peut-être pas dire ici ça s'appelle pas
bon pas bon ces dernières semaines les
équipes de production était beaucoup
mise à contribution a eu pas mal de
spéciales notamment la spéciale caméra
cachée je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
il y avait un faux stagiaire qui était
venu parler aux chroniqueurs et comme il
était censé être le neveu du patron de
des 8
personne n'avait osé de rembarrer alors
on a vu des extraits dans touche pas à
mon poste mais pas tous donc il fallait
que je vous montre ça car honnêtement le
jeune comédien était très bon
[Rires]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
les cérétans direct assure des 800
prague la vérité et il y aura une grosse
révélation de gens du club breton
mais ça bon là on sent que jean mi
aimerait bien lui en coller une et ça va
ya comme un peu d'autodérision
bon après le stagiaire été voir mathieu
mathieu c'est autre chose
non
j'aimerais la sélection
x
si tu l'as vu dans ce qu'une fois tu
m'as vu tu gardes statiques
le plus charismatique a quand même fallu
qu'on parle du monstre que vous avez
créés si c'est plus un boulard qui là le
mec il est satellisé un autre exemple
l'aï regardé une parodie delà de leurs
mots dance un peu ému parce que quand il
se regarde mathieu il a la larme à
l'oeil témoin ce qu'ils font mais bon ça
c'est un autre problème
en tout cas d'un seul coup en regardant
sa danse il va s'emballer et faire une
proposition à neutralité priscilla
regardez bien ces mouvements de tête de
priscilla à la fin on lit clairement
dans ses yeux mais mais mais qu'est ce
qu'il veut
[Musique]
cet avis
[Rires]
mais m c'est un poème à 2 dans le genre
chroniqueurs qui se veut se la jouer
cool j'en ai un autre on recevait omar
sy et roschdy zem pour la sortie de
chocolat et c'est là qu'on s'est aperçu
que jean-michel c'était vraiment l'ami
des stars
je supportais plus à l'europe
[Musique]
pas d'amendé
mais
[Applaudissements]
10ème loin il nous fait on dit bonjour
monsieur la prochaine fois dans ces cas
là quand la grosse tête menaces pour
faire retomber tout le monde le mieux
c'est de passer les meilleurs moments de
solitude de ces dernières semaines à
arte a eu beaucoup de vent c'est devenu
une éolienne cette émission moi je vous
ai fait un petit top 5 et vous allez
voir le numéro un il est très rare parce
que c'est un double vent
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et petit point soldés syrie est fin prêt
pour approcher le fait chez louis poussé
mois et la tonne il a tout mis au bayer
au sketch de jarry on veut juste rire
pas une question de vous choquer comment
on est au niveau de la lecture août
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment c'est travailler ça qu'il
voulait dire le départ quelqu'un c'est
ça c'est même pas fait clair on dirait
qu'on a fait exprès le gag et bientôt le
double regard
j'adore c'est la seule fois que ça
arrive non mais mathieu collectionne les
bons mais ils donnent ne doute pas c'est
sa force afin par exemple vous savez
bien bientôt se profile au départ à las
vegas et pendant longtemps le gros
suspense était de savoir si mathieu
delormeau les martyrs ou pas et pendant
longtemps mathieu était inquiet car ça
ça passait à ça et ces échecs lui ont
fait comprendre qu'il avait le même
destin qu un grand homme mais c'est quoi
ce avec mon avis à 2 go qui sera élu
[Musique]
aryzta excellente et s'il voit pas bien
ce que j'ai fait pour la france
pas complètement fou l'histoire peuvent
pas en plus comprendre là mais c'est
vrai c'est même destin sauf que pour
mathieu l'appel du 18 juin
c'est un appel surtaxé ma grande
surprise il y avait une autre personne
autour de la table qui voulait que m
apart jean-michel oui jean michel qui
est bienveillant avec l'un de ses
camarades c'est rare ah oui quand ça
arrive il faut le montrer a triché
tu as triché me laisse pas partir et
finissent à isabelle lauret du groupe
[Applaudissements]
la guise de stimuli justement je suis un
autre monde moi je viens d'un autre
monde donc le naturisme ouais tu peux
lui dire que ça non mais attends je
t'explique j'habite sur une île way où
on entend les petits oiseaux où il n'ya
pas de lumière ça s'appelle ligne le
vent a pris dans le sud de la france
ouais donc je suis dans un autre monde
on a n'a pas l'électricité chez nous
annonce un frère mais en tout cas ça
vous fait plaisir d'être avec vous ah
bah oui anne aussi ça nous fait très
plaisir il adore visiter les visiter le
monde n'était personne un peu bizarre
oui ça vous fait de la peine isabelle
elle est gentille zadar de paysage que
j'avais une idée un peu peut-être
préconçues que pour faire la fête
8 arras b gast avec mathieu gtpi sainz a
fait la fête ici
étaient ils te couches y travaillent
sont les six heures défilé très bon bah
vous raconterez ça plaisante bien
évidemment rêvé d'abord merci vous va
m'avoir montré là bas alors la zone qui
pique un peu mais surtout que ce que je
pense zone de turbulences
isabelle n'en veut pas à jean-michel
parce que jean michel c'est pas qu'il
aime passer ses collègues pas parfois il
se rend pas compte de ce qu'il dit et
nous honnêtement parfois on ne comprend
pas toujours
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai dit il
[Musique]
bien sûr l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé vous le voyez avec
jean-michel tous les jours voilà pas
bien ça ouais non j'avais fait la fête
la nuit pas avant l'émission et bien sûr
oui c'est exceptionnel
il est rarement dans cet état là jean
michel c'est avant tout un spécialiste
médias mais pas que il s'y connaît aussi
beaucoup en cuisine on ne savait pas la
preuve avec ce magnifique analyse de
l'offre de cent ans que nous ne va pas
jouer stéphane rotenberg
lors de sa présentation de top chef
médicaments délicatement délicatement
servat le blanc le blanc est devenu noir
le blanc et noir et noyé les normands la
cote
c'est pourri ces excellentes pas perçu
bercy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne fait finalement par des petits
oiseaux n'y a pas de lumière pas énorme
et on sait faire la tête aussi parce que
on sait faire la fête aussi ça va on
connaît fait tout à l'heure avec gilles
si je savais pas faire la fête et si on
faisait pas la fête chez nous bah ouais
je l'aurais pas rétracté c'est vrai
c'est vrai une suce projet nous ont
maintenant la spéciale hypnose mathieu
avait été programmé par sir et d'arnaud
avec un résultat très étonnant puisque
pendant toute l'émission fin il était
complètement euphoriques ils pouvaient
pas s'empêcher de danser de chanter avec
quelques absences d'un moment dans les
yeux voilà ce que vous n'avez pas vu à
l'antenne à la clinique
[Musique]
c'est systématique et le premier set
décrédibilise les fois où les gens ont
vraiment des raisons de se plaindre
c'est dommage l'adhésion est raccord
maquillage sans dieu pour que ce soit un
beau mathieu
[Musique]
ce sera le passement la japonaise yoko
lanta
deux sentiments
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un chômeur pour moi le froid
[Musique]
c'était très sympa ta très sympa tout le
moins des heureux
alors autre moment marquant de cette
spéciale mathieu avait offert je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez un beau coup
c'est un cyril vont sceller leur amour
et ça ça nous amène au moment très
gênant des quatre tiers car c'est là
c'est maintenant non non celle là c'est
pas la révélation mais c'est sa marque
de blizzard d'accord car pendant toute
l'émission cyril à chatouiller le
coussin et honnêtement je sais pas s'il
faisait exprès ou si c'est des effets
secondaires de l'hypnose mais à chaque
fois mathieu se mettaient à rire et
c'est là que ça a dérapé
car à un moment cyril a fait serment de
chatouiller le zizi du coussin ne me
demandez pas où ça se trouve je suis pas
bon d'anatomie de deux coussins
je vous laisse là c'est quand son entier
parce que là je ne sais pas comment la
décrire
et surtout écoutez bien le gémissement
de mathieu à la fin alors que plus
personne ne fait attention à lui
j'aurais pas m'avancer puisque vous
l'avez trop chatouiller zizi non à 2,7
au lieu d'utiliser sa tenue du musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vient d'ordonner à la tuque quand on
enterre c'est le prime de la vérité ah
ça y est on arrive à la vraie révélation
vous la voulez oui alors je vous
préviens ça va faire des vagues
depuis des années quelqu'un vous ment
cyril abuse de votre naïveté
ça ne pouvait plus durer et aujourd'hui
le jour du prime de la vérité les
masques vont tomber tout devient c'est
un mensonge qui durent depuis des années
sans doute le gag le plus long de
l'histoire de touche pas à mon poste
c'est parti
[Musique]
16 par 25 par 8 -
794 16 par 25 par ville - 794 vous jure
qu'il n'a pas d'oreillette 2706 ses 2400
si c'est la bonne réponse bois la jolie
12 au carré soit 12 plus 1212 moins deux
fois 12.12 par deux vous dit ça va parmi
les origines de 1910 c'est un truc c'est
de 1910 2009 110 ch vous jure que c'est
la bonne réponse et chez vous et 96 / 3
+ 36 x 72 - 619
quatre-vingt douze mois 619 en 2005 rien
et truc et je vous jure il a un donc je
le connais depuis des années c'est un
malade
mais non sera possible parce que là ça
la radio aussi donc c'est depuis des
années mais vous me connaissez mal non
la fa la radio synge ehpad dont je suis
rarement vu en calcul mental mais sinon
c'est une immonde arnaque non pas
d'oreillette j'ai regardé un canular que
j'ai fait à syrie depuis un peu plus de
deux ans alors ça a commencé à europe 1
c'est vrai et depuis ça continue à
touche pas à mon poste
le baht alors non mais je suis choquée
mais douce et bien que la vérité je vais
vous expliquer l'idée était simple faire
des calculs très compliqué sans
oreillette pour pas se faire gauler
alors bien sûr vous allez me dire il
faut quand même avoir une bonne mémoire
et pas se tromper dans les chiffres
il suffit d'être malin 2406 2406 c'est
la pole réponse de 1910
de 2005 4 06 29 10 et 20 05 6 correspond
à l'anniversaire de mon fils de ma fille
et de ma soeur dans le culte tunisien
c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur puissant
rigoler je n'avais pas les questions
qu'il est en effet toujours les mêmes
résultats c'est un an mais on s'est
arrangé à la radio aussi à la radio si
vous êtes vif
[Applaudissements]
ça a commencé une fois par hasard et
chrono saint cricq le rédacteur en chef
à europe 1 puis on a trouvé ça rigolo et
depuis on fait durer le truc juste
pourquoi je fais ça c'est parce que
maintenant quand je fais une interview
pour mon spectacle je suis en tournée
maintenant on me demande de faire des
calculs mentaux et j'ai réussi à
enfermer un moment je fais rigoler donc
je préfère dire que c'est la vérité
c'était le jour ou jamais
[Applaudissements]
une dernière question d'entendre et je
suis candidat parce que j'étais maudit
que je sais mais je me disais à tout le
monde mais je sais moi aussi avoir
dépassé son pic mais je suis sûr que ça
fait plaisir d'avoir deux judokas avec
mon père la très sexy en plus l'on garde
dernière question dans la question c'est
fort bonjour je m'appelle brigitte j'ai
lu dans un magazine que si cyril hanouna
était sympathique à la télévision quand
il n'était plus à l'antenne il mangeait
des enfants est ce vrai je n'ai pas vrai
du tout ou en tout cas les rares fois où
ça s'est passé il s'agissait d'enfants
périmés tout ce qu'on dit quand on
utilise des oeufs dans l'émission dans
la vérité c'est que depuis quelques
temps syrie est l'objet de tous les
fantasmes et ça va pas s'arrêter je peux
d'ores et déjà vous annoncer des
parutions à venir regarder psychologies
magazine cyril hanouna peut-on réussir
en étant un sale type
la france dimanche hanouna le mensonge
il appelle ses téléspectateurs mais
petite beauté un témoin anonyme déclare
en vrai ils en trouvent certains moche
le journal de mickey
après enquête c'est cyril hanouna qui
aurait tué la mère de bambi surgelés
magazine si rihanna se croyant au dessus
des lois ils brisent la chaîne du froid
est en congé des produits décongelés le
problème avec toutes ses publications
c'est qu'on parle plus l'essentiel à
savoir que touche pas à mon poste est
juste une émission de télé rigolote donc
pour couper court à tous ces bruits et
pour qu'on revienne à l'essentiel des 8
a demandé à une agence de com de dire
une bonne fois pour toute la vérité sur
le cac hanouna pour s'acheter pas au
courant voici en exclusivité ce que
l'agent sera proposé bon je vous
préviens c'est un premier jet c'est
peut-être un peu trop sobre
à l'origine la terre était composé d'un
super continent la pangée puis vint le
règne des dinosaures
il ne se passera rien de notable pendant
des siècles jusqu'à la naissance de
cyril hanouna cyril hanouna
ce nom est écrit en lettres d'or sur le
panthéon de l'humanité et sur la porte
d'entrée deux des huit personnages de
génie cyril hanouna révolutionne le
monde moderne en inventant internet le
téléphone portable
gilles verdez et le happening de la
sardine géante
mais cyril hanouna est aussi un homme de
coeur qui avec ses associations vient en
aide à ceux que l'on qualifie
pudiquement de différents souvent cité
en exemple il est une source
d'inspiration pour les plus grands mais
aussi pour les plus petits homme de
dialogue il n'hésite jamais à prendre
sur son sommeil pour discuter avec ses
amis de la télévision grand découvreur
de talents et gardent jalousement son
secret mais où les danish t-il mais si
aujourd'hui son nom est synonyme
d'excellence c'est qu'il est issu d'une
lignée de grands personnages historiques
napoléon de hannah christophe de hanouna
l'explorateur qui découvrent ibiza et
mykonos joséphine de hanouna maîtresse
de louis xiv qui influença ces grands
choix politiques lourds de la nina qui
inventa la roue
mais plus incroyable encore il y à trois
points 5 milliards d'années une simple
bactéries le anus baba est la première
forme de vie sur terre à produire de
l'oxygène
cet oxygène que nous respirons tous nous
le devons un ancêtre de cyril hanouna et
c'est ainsi de génération en génération
que c'est améliorer la lignée hanouna
pour donner naissance au meilleur
d'entre tous et dire qu'avant d'être un
monument il n'était qu'un enfant
cyril on t'aime
[Applaudissements]
notre héros merci aujourd'hui est arrivé
ciolek toutes les attentions le mec à
faux avec abobo modèle plus tard aulas
l'a inventé les cribles merci à tous a
break avec le soir vertige jamaïque
sitôt et légumes cibler tout bois pour
la paresse chico et les gypsies
[Applaudissements]
tendance
bien sûr égérie
d'ici là tous les chroniqueurs la foudre
rigueur si nos carnets reçus à bordeaux
car mon psy maman puis d'être intervenu
pour imprimer chez remercier la famille
merci à tous permet pas d'oublier
[Musique]